[Música]
el mercado común del sur El mercosur
cumple 32 años de existencia un proyecto
que tenía como idea original ser una
Unión económica de países que buscaban
generar mayor competitividad a nivel
mundial mediante la integración Después
de tres décadas los países que lo
integraron en su momento o en su inicio
se mantienen Unidos estamos hablando de
Brasil Argentina Uruguay y Paraguay pero
las diferencias entre los integrantes
hacen que el avance de este bloque
económico sea lento muy lento los ires y
venires políticos también han desviado
un poco digamos el norte que tenía
inicialmente el mercosur pasando de ser
un bloque económico también a tener unos
tintes de bloque político que tampoco
logró dar los frutos esperados pero
veamos más detalles en el siguiente
informe que preparó la redacción de
France 24
esta fábrica produce autopartes en
Buenos Aires actualmente funciona a
pleno rendimiento las exportaciones del
sector aumentaron un 11,6% en 2022 sin
embargo temen que esto se revierta
después del acuerdo entre mercosur y la
Unión Europea el sector Automotriz
podría ser el más afectado por el
acuerdo ya que la industria en Europa es
más competitiva y moderna y sus
vehículos no tendrían aranceles así lo
explican desde la asociación de fábricas
argentinas de componentes que
representan a más de 200 empresas para
un sector con más de 55.000 personas
empleadas que no hay inversión implica
que luego la producción de ciertos
productos ya no se haga o de ciertos
productos de nueva con nuevas
tecnologías se decida que no se hacen
acá se hacen en Europa eso implica que
va a haber menos demanda de mano de obra
en Uruguay el país vecino desde hace más
de 50 años Lancer uniformes para
empresas de todo el mundo
mercosur fue muy importante para el
textil uruguayo sobre todo durante
periodos de estabilidad ahora Uruguay
estudia un tratado de libre comercio con
china al margen de mercosur la cámara de
la vestimenta de Uruguay teme que el
sector pueda desaparecer con ese acuerdo
por la diferencia competitiva o sea
pantalones a una camisa algunas cosas
que todavía se siguen fabricando en
Uruguay y donde todavía somos un poco
competitivos así como estábamos
este Ahora sí de golpe desaparecen los
recargos y eso sería ya el punto final
de la industria
la sus 32 años mercosur espera ratificar
en Julia el acuerdo con la Unión Europea
mientras discuten con Uruguay un acuerdo
con china en conjunto o uno separado que
podría resquebrajar la unión pues
justamente 32 años después de su inicio
vale la pena analizar los logros de esa
integración económica que tampoco logró
a plenitud digamos consolidar una Unión
aduanera y que a lo largo de los años
algunos de los integrantes reclaman un
bloque menos proteccionista y más
abierto a tener acuerdos con otros
mercados algunos de sus retos van
justamente en esa línea lograr esa
ratificación de ese acuerdo con la Unión
Europea y también concretar algún tipo
de acuerdo con china entre otros tantos
que dejan Entonces estos 32 años de
mercosur cuáles son los aciertos Cuáles
son los errores Cuál es el futuro que le
espera Y por qué le cuesta tanto también
América Latina integrarse hoy lo vamos a
debatir aquí en France 24 lo vamos a
analizar y para conversar sobre este
tema hemos invitado a Delia flores ella
es especialista en temas relacionados
con el mercosur empresaria en servicio
al comercio exterior aduana y Transporte
internacional de cargas ella se conecta
desde la ciudad de Buenos Aires en
Argentina y desde Montevideo se conecta
Ignacio bartezagui Él es director del
Instituto de negocios internacionales de
la Universidad Católica de Uruguay y
también el doctor en relaciones
internacionales ustedes nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte del
debate de esta conversación del análisis
por supuesto dejen sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
nos encuentran en Twitter en Facebook y
también en instagram nos encuentran como
arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f-24 y a mí me encuentran como
arroba santilogo en Twitter no olviden
también que todos los contenidos del
programa están disponibles en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
muy bien comienzo entonces dándole la
bienvenida a Delia a la ciudad de Buenos
Aires Delia Gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en el debate en France 24
y El Punto de partida para esta
discusión el balance que usted hace de
estos 32 años de mercosur sus luces sus
sombras y sus aciertos y desaciertos
bienvenida
Hola qué tal bueno Muchas gracias por
invitarme a formar parte de este panel
de debate bueno Yo siempre digo que el
mercosur arrancó muy bien con mucho
impulso con una visión fundacional de un
mercado de llegar a ser un mercado común
pero alguna parte quedó en el camino y
es como que no tiene avances hace diez
años o quizás más quedó en la unión
aduanera algunos le dicen imperfecta lo
dicen en construcción pero quedó frenada
quien sabe por cuestiones políticas por
falta de voluntad
política para para llegar a decidir
cuestiones tributarias y es una pena
realmente porque hoy vemos después de 32
años vemos un mercosur prácticamente
paralizado con muchas
idas y vueltas y este
conflictos así políticos a veces también
por por distintas identidades políticas
que solamente afectan a nuestra Unión
aduanera Sí y ahora saludó al otro lado
en la otra orilla del río la plata a
Ignacio bartesagui en la ciudad de
Montevideo en la capital uruguaya
bienvenido Ignacio como siempre Un gusto
también tenerlo en el programa y la
misma pregunta para El Punto de partida
su balance de estos 32 años de mercosur
y desvenir es luces y Sombras
un gusto Santiago saludarte gracias por
la invitación sí como decía Delia Yo te
diría que el mercado común del sur
inició muy bien en sus primeros años
logró bajar aranceles logró armonizar
ciertas normas logró firmar varios
tratados importantes logró crear
instituciones logró crear derecho
derivado pero en determinados momentos
se estancó y se estancó a partir
fundamentalmente del 99 en adelante con
esa devaluación de Brasil que después se
acompañó por un proceso de politización
que creo que es en el fondo lo que decía
Delia un bloque que olvidó sus objetivos
originarios y no logró conformar lo que
dicen sus tratados el tratado de
Asunción es muy claro en su Artículo
primero Establece que deberíamos ser un
mercado común una Unión aduanera y una
zona y comercio plena y no somos ninguna
de esas tres cosas estamos muy lejos de
ser un mercado común que sería el máximo
nivel de integración solo alcanzado por
la Unión Europea a nivel mundial somos
un año una manera muy precaria
que está en como decía Delia en
perfeccionamiento o en construcción pero
está muy lejos de hacer una Unión
aduanera pero tampoco somos una zona
libre comercio plena porque tenemos
excepciones y una gran cantidad de
Barreras norancelarias y entonces yo
creo que el mercosur tuvo un inicio
Interesante pero después se estancó no
solo en el cumplimiento de sus objetivos
originarios sino también Santiago en
algo muy importante que es lo que decías
también en la en la nota introductoria
se estancó en abrirse al mundo hoy el
mercosur no le está otorgando a los
empresarios la posibilidad de tener
acceso a nuevos mercados porque no ha
logrado cerrar acuerdos de consideración
Ignacio continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda la inversa usted menciona esos
puntos claves que son las bases de lo
que es el mercosur y dice que muchas de
ellas pues no se han logrado concretar a
lo largo de estos 32 años tres décadas
después entonces hoy en día Qué es el
mercosur
Bueno es un proceso de integración que
no ha cumplido con su objetivo
originarios y para mí lo peor es que no
muestra ningún interés inalcanzable no
es que yo te pueda decir estamos vamos a
darle veinte años más al mercosur porque
dentro de 20 años más Sí vamos a
alcanzar esos objetivos no es un proceso
de integración que quedó a mitad de
camino que entonces es bien importante
reformularlo es bien importante
sincerarnos y reconocer que nunca vamos
a hacer lo que dijimos que íbamos a
hacer de 26 de Marzo de 1991 Entonces es
un es un mercosur que ha quedado algo
anticuado para enfrentar un mundo muy
Dinámico con nuevas tendencias entonces
que de dos modernizarlo y debemos
cambiarlo si es que no queremos que
caiga en la irrelevancia qué piensa
usted de esta de este Punto de partida
de Ignacio y también le pregunto
entendiendo entonces este estancamiento
que hubo en una digamos en una primera
fase debido a esa devaluación que tuvo
en Brasil hace algunos años tal parece
que el estancamiento pues se perpetuó el
bloque quedó completamente paralizado en
muchos sentidos hoy en día hay interés
por volver a poner en marcha el mercosur
a tratar de lograr esos retos y esas
solidificar esas bases iniciales que
todavía no nos pudieron ser concretadas
en estos 332 años
yo siento que lo que el interés va
fluctuando no hay nunca en estos últimos
diez años nos hemos encontrado un
interés común es decir que todo que
todos estemos interesados a la vez es
como que en un momento se interesa uno
en otro momento se interesa otro
entonces este está muy como decía antes
no muy influido por la política por la
ideología y y así es como que no
avanzamos hemos pasado como este decía
mi compañero de panel hemos pasado por
muchas barreras arancelarias para
arancelarias sí es verdad Entonces este
somos socios entre comillas porque
siempre hay alguna cosa que está
bombardeando o que está afectando este
esta sociedad del mercosur
y y yo veo que hay poca voluntad también
ese ese también es el tema no me parece
que hay poca voluntad de todas las
partes y si vamos un todo si vamos a
analizar la voluntad del todo Me parece
que hay poca voluntad porque cuando hay
voluntad y voluntad política
fundamentalmente
Caiga quien caiga como digamos las cosas
se hacen y bueno se sacrificara uno
alguien este sacrificará esto El otro
pondrálo es decir cuando hay voluntad
política el camino se encuentra hoy yo
no veo Esa voluntad política
Lamentablemente Ignacio de acuerdo en
ese punto hay falta de voluntad hay
falta de interés y también yo le quiero
Añadir otro otro punto para analizar y
que puede ser un también uno de los
puntos que tal vez empezó a generar
problemas allá al interior del mercosur
no eran dos economías muy grandes con
otras dos economías no tan grandes que
esperaban mucho de este bloque esperaban
muchísimo de esos dos socios grandes
estoy hablando de Brasil de Argentina y
tal vez Uruguay Paraguay se quedaron
esperando algo que nunca sucedió había
una no era muy muy bien compensada las
cargas de los de los países que lo
integran totalmente Santiago dos cosas
primero que la voluntad política ha
estado ausente durante mucho tiempo es
verdad que ahora con con Lula Esto va a
cambiar porque Lula quiere volver a
poner en el centro del mercosur volver a
poner en el centro la unasur pero lo
hace de un lugar muy político que esto
es riesgoso porque no quiere decir
necesariamente que la politización del
bloque sea buena a la hora de
perfeccionarlo y alcanzar los objetivos
entonces allí tenemos un tema y con
respecto al otro que decías Sí hay mucha
teoría escrita sobre esto Santiago
vinculado a que las asimetrías son tan
grandes entre Brasil incluso entre
Brasil Argentina pero Brasil Argentina
fundamentalmente con Paraguay con
Uruguay que no se ha dado ese traspaso
de de integración regional los intereses
nacionales siguieron primando frente los
intereses regionales entonces
este sigue siendo un acuerdo de lógicas
muy bilaterales entonces a la audiencia
es importante recordar cómo fue la
historia de mercosur antes de la firma
del tratado de Asunción en la década del
80 los antecedentes de mercosur Son
acuerdos bilaterales entre Argentina y
Brasil y esa lógica de relación entre
estos dos grandes no ha cambiado mucho Y
todavía hoy el mercosur sigue siendo de
cierta forma un acuerdo bastante
bilateral donde Paraguay y Uruguay
todavía no han logrado entrar en esas
lógicas de una integración regional que
nunca terminó de existir
Ignacio Y qué hay de la politización
entiendo que en algún momento de la
historia latinoamericana hubo un auge de
los partidos de izquierda esto también
permeó un poco el mercosur y desvió su
rumbo Esto está pasando factura al
bloque el día de hoy o es este factor de
la politización como usted lo han
nombrado que puede tener un nuevo
impulso ahora que el presidente Lula ha
llegado a pues a gobernar en Brasil Está
tratando de darle un nuevo aire a este
bloque
al mercosur en sí piensa usted que la
politización aquí es necesaria es
necesario que haya entendimiento
político entre los países o hay ejemplo
digamos en la Unión Europea donde la
politización está completamente de lado
y los países logran una integración
la politización que se dio en su momento
con el impulso de Lula en Mujica los
krishna en Argentina y luo en en
Paraguay derivó en algo muy malo para el
mercosur que fueron más instituciones
por ejemplo la creación de parlamento de
mercosur sin ningún sentido la
ampliación del bloque aceptando a
Venezuela hoy suspendida por la cláusula
democrática el proceso de politización
de aquella época fue muy malo ahora el
de hoy con Lula vamos a ver todavía no
lo sabemos si politizar implica querer
asumir Los costos de la integración y
que Lula diga Ahora sí voy a probar por
ejemplo el acuerdo mercurio Unión
Europea o iba a impulsar para que del
lado del mercosur es acuerdo avance
bueno podría ser una politización
positiva pero la de la época anterior de
estos gobiernos que recién señalé Fue
muy mala para el mercosur porque creó
más instituciones lo politizó y se
olvidó de lo importante que es que es un
mercosur de comercio mercosur que
necesita más oportunidades para los
empresarios hacer negocios Y eso quedó
de lado Delia su opinión sobre este tema
de la politización y añado otro factor
para analizar el tema de las decisiones
por consenso esto ha jugado también en
contra del bloque a la hora de tomar
decisiones fundamentales rumbo a esa
integración completa rumbo a estabilizar
el bloque rumbo a salir adelante
llevamos tres décadas esperando que
despegue
bueno hubo una época de mucha idea mucho
idealismo que estaba este conformado por
ese eje Chávez kirchner
Morales Evo Morales decir si bien
Bolivia no formaba parte del mercosur
Pero había mucha ideología
que me parece en este es un momento
diferente es posible sí que la la
cuestión política impulsada por Lula
creo que puede ser beneficiosa en esta
en esta nueva parte de la historia del
mercosur Yo creo que con un Lula más
expediente yo creo que va podría llegar
a ser un motor que impulse al mercosur
Igualmente
Argentina Próximamente está en
elecciones Y si vamos a hablar de
política no sabemos lo que va a pasar
dentro de unos meses pero
yo creo que Lula puede ser un motor que
impulse el mercosur Lula de Lia puede
ser esa figura de Liderazgo que le ha
faltado al mercosur a lo largo de estos
años puede ser es el presidente que que
lo pueda llevar y con quien se
apalancaría con un nuevo gobierno en
Argentina o tal vez con el presidente la
calle de Uruguay puede ser como esa esa
pieza que empiecen a hacer engranaje
como lo ve usted
yo creo que Lula puede ser el impulsor
creo que necesita impulsar ese mercosur
porque hay hay mucha hay muchas alianzas
por si vamos a hablar de los dos países
más grandes del mercosur no Brasil y
Argentina hay mucha interacción hay
muchas empresas binacionales hay
abastecimientos de un lado y de otro por
ejemplo en el estado de Río Grande o
azul hay mucha industria que exporta a
la Argentina entonces Lula necesita
impulsar ese mercosur porque si no hay
mucha mucha generación de Divisas que se
iría perdiendo Entonces Por ese motivo
yo creo que sí y puede ser Uruguay Sí sí
puede ser la calle Pou el que el el nexo
digamos ese eslabón que faltaría para
para lograr digamos ese camino de la
revitalización del mercosur
Ignacio su opinión Lula como esta figura
de liderazgo apalancado con el
presidente de la calle Pou que hay que
decirlo hace algunos años debido también
el contexto político en cierta forma era
como la piedra en el zapato para el
mercosur por esa negociación que Está
avanzando entre Montevideo y Beijing por
unos acercamientos para para tratar de
lograr un tratado de libre comercio
Uruguay era visto como el El Malo del
vecindario porque ver lograr este
acuerdo fuera de los pactos del mercosur
está bien Pero por qué lo quiere hacer
afuera lo quiere hacer afuera porque
mercosur no se abre entonces la
propuesta de flexibilización de Uruguay
tiene que ver con bueno llevamos 32 años
juntos y no hemos cerrado un acuerdo
comercial con la Unión Europea no lo
cerramos con Estados Unidos no lo
cerramos con Japón no lo cerramos con
Corea del Sur no tenemos acuerdos con
ningún centro de consumo importante a
nivel mundial Ese es eso por eso Uruguay
lo impulsa entonces Lula puede ser
alguien que desactive este problema
podría pero ojo que las noticias que
están viniendo a nivel de los
negociadores no son tan buenas respecto
a las negociaciones para los agregados
al acuerdo mercosuña europea en términos
ambientales donde Lula estaría
tirando un poquito para atrás esa
propuesta de la Unión Europea Entonces
tenemos que pensar en un Lula que va a
confirmar ese liderazgo y para
confirmarlo tiene que dar señales claras
de que quiere abrirse al mundo Y hoy no
están tan claras esas señales porque
Lula vuelve a plantear de cierta forma
alguna visión algo proteccionista de su
mercado interno entonces va a ir muy de
a poco con las negociaciones Entonces yo
creo que Lula puede ser un actor
interesante para reactivar el mercosur
lo puede hacer A través del futuro
gobierno de Argentina que como decía
Adrián no sabemos Quién va a ser lo
puede hacer A través de la calle Pou
pero necesariamente tiene que evitar
caer en la tentación de politizar
demasiado el mercosur y tiene que dar
señales claras de que una vez por todas
Brasil está dispuesta a abrirse al mundo
claro también hay que decir que Paraguay
también está en un escenario electoral y
está próximo a celebrar elecciones
presidenciales entonces también hay que
esperar qué cambio político pueda haber
allí en Paraguay que también es una
pieza importante aquí en el en el
mercosur es entonces Ignacio continuó
con usted para hacer la ronda la inversa
es entonces
tratando de plantear un futuro escenario
para el mercosur que sea un bloque
un poco más flexible un poco menos
proteccionista y que le permita a los
países tener una integración entre ellos
cuatro pero a la vez tener la capacidad
de negociar por fuera es esto viable es
este un escenario factible en términos
de comercio y de integración lograr
sumar las los dos aspectos
hizo Santiago Debería ser en el marco de
una de un sinceramiento del mercosur
porque de hecho el mercosur ya es muy
flexible Porque todos los miembros
violan las normas y no pasa
absolutamente nada y hace años que no se
activa el sistema de solución de
controversias que es el que defiende a
los empresarios cuando uno de los países
no cumple con lo comprometido en los
tratados entonces que el mercosur es
flexible ya lo es pero lo que vos
propones es el sinceramiento es decir
vamos hacia nuevos tratados vamos a
reconocer que no somos lo que dice el
artículo primero del tratado de Asunción
y que no lo vamos a hacer nunca entonces
para eso sí sería necesario sincerarse
reformular el mercosur y pasar a un
acuerdo más moderno que quede en una
zona libre comercio donde le dé la
oportunidad a los países de abrirse al
mundo a sus tiempos y con sus propias
estrategias y también poder agregar los
nuevos temas del comercio internacional
porque la agenda de mercosur todavía
sigue centrada en bienes pero no abarca
todos los nuevos asuntos del comercio
internacional que ya están en los
tratados a nivel global entonces creo
que el camino justamente es ese es ir
para atrás no para adelante reconocer
que el mercosur nunca va a ser un
mercado común quedarnos con una zona
libre y comercio y dejar que los
miembros puedan abrirse al mundo de
forma unilateral para mí esa sería la
propuesta Pero reconozco que es bastante
difícil desde el punto de vista político
porque Brasil no quiere reconocer que el
mercosura fracasado porque para Brasil
el mercosur es una marca forex lo
posiciona como instrumento en su
política de global Player
Delia su opinión sobre este aspecto que
propongo una integración pero que haya
flexibilidad y que cada quien pueda
negociar con quien quiera fuera de sus
fronteras
creo que absolutamente necesario Eso
modernizar flexibilizar sentarnos y
tirar todas las cartas de nuevo porque
así como está no funciona y sí el
acuerdo como está hoy el tratado de
Asunción como está hoy es como que todo
no se tiene que hacer en bloque las este
las negociaciones digamos con terceros
se tienen que hacer en una decisión en
conjunta pero no se está haciendo
Entonces habría que sentarse y
sincerarse pero necesita un cambio
profundo el mercosur necesita así de un
debate y de un cambio profundo para eso
hace falta nuevamente la voluntad
política bueno y le preguntó a los dos
esto qué costo tiene para los países
integrantes quién puede tomar este
liderazgo para hacer ese sinceramiento Y
esto qué costo puede tener para el
bloque para los países a nivel político
como lo ve Ignacio
yo creo que Lula no va a dar ese paso
Santiago no no creo que habilite la
posibilidad de que el mercosur se
transforme y reconozca que no va a
cumplir con su tratado le va a dar
largas va a intentar darle algunas
concesiones a los países que los
reclaman Ojalá que una de esas
concesiones sea la posibilidad de que
Uruguay Avance en un tlc bilateral con
china mientras Los Socios no lo quieren
porque ese es un punto interesante
Uruguay no es que quiere sacar ventaja
argentino de Brasil o de Paraguay que
recordemos tiene relaciones con Taiwán
es que Uruguay dice si tú no querés
avanzar Permíteme a mí avanzar en el
marco de una flexibilización Eso sí ese
tipo de contención puntual creo que la
habilitaría de cierta forma Lula O
estaría dentro de las posibilidades pero
abrir la posibilidad de una
renegociación más fuerte más seria más
profunda lo veo bastante difícil pero
también dependerá del próximo gobierno
de Argentina y en Paraguay Claro en
Paraguay cambian menos las posiciones
respecto al mercosur siempre son muy
conservadoras en Argentina pueden
cambiar más en el próximo gobierno si es
que se da el cambio que prevén las
encuestas podría venir de vuelta Un
gobierno que apure o presione a Lula a
un mercosur más moderno más rápido y más
abierto al mundo y eso Por supuesto que
para Uruguay sería muy positivo Delia y
viendo el escenario a la inversa es
decir viendo todo este escenario que los
gobiernos Pues poco quieren negociar y
hablar sobre esta necesidad de
modernizar el bloque no hay mucho
interés en tratar de cambiar las
posiciones todas las negociaciones toman
muchísimo tiempo vemos que llevan 20
años tratando de negociar algo con la
Unión Europea uno de los Pilares
fundamentales es el consenso y no se
logra fácilmente
no sería también un escenario posible
dejar hasta acá quedarse con lo logrado
hasta ahora en estos 32 años o dar un
poco marcha hacia atrás en algunos de
los pactos alcanzados y abandonar la
idea del mercosur
no yo creo que abandonar la idea del
mercosur no yo creo que es posible que
que pregunta
qué pregunta
yo tengo
tengo no sé optimismo en que quizás en
esta nueva etapa entre Lula y y esta
nueva etapa que se inicia se hagan los
cambios definitivos de los cambios
profundos que necesita el mercosur y si
no quedará como está porque En
definitiva como está tampoco es decir
para algo sirve
tenemos una arancela unificado tenemos
este una arancel externo común unificado
hay una hay una zona de libre comercio
decir algunas cosas se han logrado
entonces tirar para atrás lo que ya lo
logró yo creo que sería una cosa de
necio claro el tema el tema es que no no
es un tema prioritario para ninguna de
las agendas de Ninguno de los gobiernos
en torno en este momento Ignacio su
opinión echar para atrás puede ser un
puede ser un o dejarlo hasta acá puede
ser un escenario
yo diría dejarlo hasta acá pero sin
salirse no no creo que creo que ningún
país y ningún gobierno está manejando la
opción de salirse del mercosur y incluso
tampoco lo maneja la calle en Uruguay no
es una opción sí es una opción reconocer
que se ha llegado hasta acá y como decía
Delia hay aspectos positivos porque
tenemos cierta unificación en el arancel
con muchísimas excepciones pero cierto
unificación hay tenemos libre comercio
salvo en algunos productos que están
decepcionados Y más allá de las barreras
van a ser áreas que decíamos tenemos
armonizaciones normas técnicas en normas
sanitarias también el mercosur tiene una
gran cantidad de normas comunes en otras
áreas como educación como una gran
cantidad de temas que tienen que ver con
la cooperación internacional que son
relevantes entonces uno dice no no hay
que tirar todo para atrás pero en lo
económico y comercial hay que reconocer
que se llegó hasta determinado punto y
que no va a ser posible seguir avanzando
más allá entonces ahí donde decimos nos
quedamos con la zona lírico y comercio
funcione como funcione intentamos
mejorarla le agregamos servicios
intentamos eliminar las barreras pero
nos olvidamos esto de la unión aduanera
y nos olvidamos Esto del mercado común y
nos olvidamos esto de que vamos a ir
juntos para todos lados Yo creo que esa
es la discusión que no tiene por qué ser
blanco negro me quedo o me voy creo que
hay caminos intermedios que pueden
explorarse pero para en todos los casos
termina siendo más una definición
política no económica y no técnica
porque opciones hay muchas pero para
ellos se necesita Yo creo que un Brasil
no nos olvidemos que Brasil es el 70% de
cualquier indicador del mercosur
Entonces si Brasil no está en la misma
página que Uruguay que Argentina que
Paraguay en esto iba a ser bastante
difícil que se reconozca cierto fracaso
del proceso de integración y se va a
seguir dándole largas Ahora hay un punto
de de corte de quiebre que puede ser
fundamental y todos lo pensamos si se
cerraba el acuerdo mercosuña Europea el
escenario es otro y el mercosur
recuperaría muchísimo aire y pasaría de
la liga de fútbol mundial Entonces no
cerrar el acuerdo con la Unión Europea
es un error estratégico también para la
agenda interna de mercosur y para sus
para bueno justamente iba a preguntarle
sobre este acuerdo porque también hace
poco hubo una declaración del canciller
de Brasil Mauro vieira que le pidió por
ejemplo a España que es un país que
tiene una buena relación con con Brasil
y bueno y en general con los otros
países que integran el mercosur con
Uruguay Argentina y Paraguay para que se
involucrara un poco más
durante el periodo de la presidencia que
tiene de la Unión Europea para que
tratara como de revivir esta negociación
Y tratar de sacar este acuerdo adelante
Usted me dice que Ignacio que esto sería
prácticamente como darle un respiro al
mercosur sería una especie de segundo
aire si se llega a ese acuerdo qué tan
fundamental es para el mercosur tener
ese acuerdo con la Unión Europea y qué
tan importante es en este momento para
la Unión Europea poder acceder a un
mercado como el mercosur y ya le doy la
palabra de ella no usted
el canciller vieira debería hacer los
esfuerzos para aceptar las propuestas
técnicas que Brasil hoy no está
convencido de aceptar entonces la Unión
Europea como negocia la comisión europea
que es Supra nacional ese problema
todavía no lo tiene porque negocia solo
la comisión europea va a tener por
supuesto en 2024 si se cierra un acuerdo
técnico va a tener el problema político
que ya sabemos que lo tiene con Francia
con Países Bajos con Hungría con otros
miembros de la Unión Europea pero en el
caso de mercosur vieira tiene
responsabilidad también porque es el
propio Brasil que tiene que aceptar o no
y tiene que permitir avanzar en lo
técnico pero sin lugar a dudas el
acuerdo para mercosur es importantísimo
en esto que decíamos de darle vida al
bloque y para la Unión Europea en un
escenario de guerra en Ucrania y en un
escenario de la confección de un nuevo
orden mundial vaya si es importante
cerrar un acuerdo con el mercosur porque
lo posicionaría muy bien en toda América
Latina del Caribe y en mercosur es un
gran proveedor de alimentos en
construcción es un gran proveedor de
energía y en ese sentido creo que el
acuerdo adquiere suma relevancia también
para Europa pero más en términos
geopolíticos y no tanto económico bueno
y le preguntó a Delia por un caso
particular es el de Argentina en ese
orden de ideas y teniendo ese posible
acuerdo o ese acuerdo pues que están
negociación que respiro le daría
Argentina que tiene una economía con
muchas complicaciones en este momento
muchísimas dificultades
derivadas de múltiples problemas
políticos económicos la pandemia pero
pero esto en el caso particular de
Argentina no sería una apuesta del todo
por el todo en este tipo de
negociaciones y uno no ve a Argentina en
esa sintonía
Bueno yo este veía el informe previo a
este debate y pensaba no las Industrias
autopartistas por ejemplo en el acuerdo
de autopartista entre Argentina y Brasil
es un que uno de los motores más
importantes de comercio bilateral
Argentina no cumplió no cumplió el el
con el proceso digamos que tendría que
cumplir a esta altura
o sea yo creo sinceramente creo que esto
ayuda a la competencia siempre ayuda a
mejorar más que traer aire yo creo que
nos va a obligar a a mejorar a levantar
Es como empezar a jugar en otras ligas y
a mejorar también el estándar nuestro de
nuestra industria entonces creo que
puede llegar a ser positivo seguramente
van a haber reclamos porque Bueno
hay cierta incomodidad digamos cuando
entra a jugar y un tercero grande como
es la Unión Europea pero yo creo que
puede ser beneficioso para la industria
Argentina y para la Argentina en sí como
para la economía que yo creo que en eso
hay hay cierta particularidad de los
latinoamericanos y hay cierto miedo
ustedes me corregirán hay cierto miedo
también en jugársela un poco en estos
mercados grandes en luchar para ser más
competitivos son pocos los que se
arriesgan a estas grandes ligas como le
dice Delia Ignacio así como le pregunto
a Delia por el caso específico de
Argentina yo le tengo que preguntar por
Uruguay que es un país que hemos le
hemos estado siguiendo aquí los pasos en
esa negociación con china ustedes tuvo
con nosotros en otro programa hablando
específicamente de ese de ese tema esta
negociación con Beijing en qué escenario
está y de llegar esto un buen Puerto
esto representaría un posible retiro o
pausa de Uruguay en el mercosur si logra
llegar a una negociación exitosa con
China
Uruguay intentó en primera instancia
Santiago conseguir la flexibilización
del mercosur para que el bloque de
cierta forma del punto de vista legal
acepte el proceso que estaba siguiendo
Uruguay con china eso no fue posible
especialmente por la negativa de
Argentina recordemos que el gobierno
anterior de bolsonaro sí apoyó este
proceso Uruguay y entonces se avanzó en
los últimos meses en la elaboración de
un estudio de factibilidad para la firma
de un tlc entre Uruguay y China que fue
cerrado y dio resultados positivos ahora
china está en consultas internas para
ver si se da el inicio de las
negociaciones formales ya lanzando la
primera ronda de negociación Por
supuesto que china también está
observando Mientras tanto Cuál es la
opinión de Brasil respecto a esto y como
Uruguay maneja esta situación con los
miembros del mercosur Entonces el
proceso ya está iniciado con un estudio
de factibilidad pero hoy no estamos
todavía negociando el acuerdo porque no
se inició formalmente las rondas de
negociación estamos a la espera de que
de El OK Para iniciar las negociaciones
que Uruguay por supuesto está esperando
y en términos de impacto en el informe
se hablaba de del sector textil o de la
vestimenta bueno es como decía Delia los
sectores reciben impactos por supuesto
por apertura comercial algunos ganan
otros pierden es imposible que todos
ganen los que los que pierden tienen que
hacer algunos ajustes de competitividad
y de productividad para poder seguir
subsistiendo pero lo importante aquí es
gana más de los que pierden lo que tiene
que hacer el estado y el gobierno es
decidir que si ganan más de los que
pierden avanzar igual y por supuesto que
en el marco intereses entre Uruguay
china gana mucho más sectores que los
que pierden y por eso Uruguay está
decidido avanzar claro me queda ya un
par de minutos menos de un par de
minutos para finalizar el programa
quiero que hagamos las conclusiones de
lo que deja pues lo que ha dejado estos
32 años de mercosur pero sobre todo lo
que viene para para mantener a flote
este este bloque como lo decía yo hace
unos minutos cuando no es una prioridad
de las agendas de los gobiernos de turno
en este momento y más cuando hay dos
gobiernos cerrando en el caso de
Argentina y de Paraguay y que llegarán
otros dos gobiernos pues empezaron un
nuevo capítulo en la historia política
de esos países y no sabemos si el
mercosur hace parte de esas prioridades
comienzo Entonces por Delia en Buenos
Aires para la conclusión
Bueno yo creo que este yendo al título
de la nota de hoy del debate de hoy
sobrevive o se renueva yo creo que
sobrevive sí y es posible que se renueve
también y más en este contexto global
con tantas cosas que nos han pasado en
estos últimos años donde se está
Inclusive la geopolítica y en los
mercados están reacomodando
permanentemente y hay bastante
incertidumbre en una serie de aspectos y
las cadenas de valor las cadenas también
es decir las cadenas de abastecimiento
están buscando más la cercanía Yo creo
que es un buen momento para que el
mercosur como visión estratégica de
nuestros líderes este lo renueven
entonces
creo que continúe y que continúe sí sí
es un momento donde hay muchos cambios
globales y esta estaría muy bueno que el
mercosur aproveche este momento Ignacio
rápidamente muy puntual su su conclusión
yo creo que siguiendo con el título Yo
creo que sobrevive si se renueva si no
se renueva corre el riesgo de no
sobrevivir en mercosur tiene que
modernizarse tiene que flexibilizarse y
tiene que accionarse a las nuevas
tendencias internacionales y para eso se
necesita mucha voluntad política porque
si no vamos a seguir perdiendo
oportunidades Ignacio ortelia un gustazo
conversar con ustedes sobre este tema
Muchísimas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros y ustedes Muchas gracias por la
sintonía sigan con nosotros
[Música]